well i definitely am the thirstiest
member of the franchise especially after
all the sweating i've been doing
um
day in the life making thousands of
dollars selling my tata sweat
in
bottles all you need is bottles sun
cha-chas and sit out like a maple tree
for hours stephanie you sold your farts
in a jar and you made what over two
hundred thousand dollars
yes i did right it's quite a crazy time
in my life
and now you're selling your boob sweat
and making five thousand dollars a day
did you say that yes i am you know i've
been kind of blessed in this department
and i'm quite a sweaty person
i'm also the ceo and founder of a fan
subscription platform called unfiltered
so i get a lot of requests on there from
my fans and
they like to see me sweat so i thought
you know what i put two and two together
let me sell my boob sweat what do you
say to those who feel as if you would do
anything for attention i think at the
end of the day i'm not really hurting
anybody
boob sweat isn't hurting anybody i think
if anything it's more annoying to myself
because
i'm sweating and that's annoying to me
and only me
um and i think that everybody just needs
to
have a good laugh and just
enjoy the story for what it is it's just
boob sweat it's just it's just farts
it's just boob sweat i have no fear of
judgment at all i think i have this one
life to live and i really just want to
make money so i can be happy and provide
for myself and for those that i love and
and live the best life possible
that's interesting you say you don't
judgment doesn't really affect you like
that because there are some harsh
comments out there some people refer to
you as one of the thirstiest members
from the 90-day franchise
yeah
like how do you how do you deal with
that you really is it really that easy
for it to roll off your shoulders yeah
well i definitely am the thirstiest
member of the franchise especially after
all the sweating i've been doing i don't
think there's anything wrong with being
thirsty
and being ambitious and being an
entrepreneur and i'm very grateful for
90 day fiance and for for that show
giving me a platform to do what i do
um
and yeah
at least you own it yeah yeah i have no
i have no shame in the game
i mean people call me a cloud chaser
but i don't think i'm a cloud chaser i'm
an opportunity chaser
hmm
okay okay some people might see that as
the same people don't see where i've
come from
they don't see that i
you know did not start with a lot of
opportunities in my life me and my
mother moved to this country
and we couch-surfed we did not have a
lot of money in the beginning and so
i
strive i've strived to build a life for
myself and in the past two years i've
been able to buy a home and and build
this life for myself there isn't just
one path to success
and uh you know just go just go for it
right and don't
listen to what others say
uh do what makes you happy
uh even if it
makes other people roll their eyes at
you
yeah you mentioned your mom how does she
feel about your business ventures
your farts and boob sweat
yes so at first she was very judgmental
of it not too happy about it but i think
as a mom her primary focus is just that
i'm safe
so with the farts and the boob sweat and
all of that she was just really worried
about that whole hospitalization thing
she wanted to make sure i was okay right
and now with the boob sweat she's just
like please use sunscreen please don't
stay out there too long
like she's just
she's so worried about that um but i'm
probably gonna put a sauna in my house
and um i don't know i don't really know
how long i'm going to keep up with it
it's just kind of like a it's like a fun
little thing it's a fun little gimmick
well people are buying your boobs what
for 300 to 500 a bottle
yes why do you think that's ridiculous
like
absolutely
okay why do you think what do you think
it is
um i have a lot of devoted fans uh that
kind of pivoted from the fart jars over
to the boob sweat they you know i mean i
guess they're just the classic sims they
they love what i do they love the
products that i sell and
they are extremely devoted to
to just supporting whatever venture
out there that i pursue
so
i mean i i know it it's ridiculous but i
guess it's just that it's just what it
is and i have given out some discounts
depending on how much of a volume there
is per vial so you know if it's a
smaller amount 300 i even gave someone a
discount of like a hundred dollars
so
you know but but the larger volume five
hundred dollars what do you do with it i
just don't know what they are going to
do with your boob slit like smell it
it's speaking of that i do have a
question which you probably really can't
answer because i don't want it to mess
up your business but do you ever add
water
that's a lot of boobs with like this
well
um i you know i would i would never i
would never adulterate the product with
water um but actually i will say that i
had a complaint
um a couple days ago that one of the
vials
had
a really really strong coat and smell of
spf lotion in it
and i think that's where i'm running
into some of the issues with doing it
outside
because like i have to put up all the
parts i'm sorry they don't need to be
picky
they want to buy your boobs what you
want to be thinking about it smells like
sunscreen
i know but like they i guess this guy
wanted like the pure stuff and i had so
much sunscreen on that day that like so
much suntan lotion was getting into the
into the bottle
and i'm just like but i i would
otherwise burn
like i'm sorry i can't help it so i i
got my first complaint and i was like
very thrown off guard by it and i that's
when i was like well shoot i guess maybe
i have to get a sauna because it's like
it's either
burn in the sun or
get people upset that it smells like
suntan lotion so yeah i mean it's it's a
mess
you know i had my own
preconceived notions coming into this
but i'm getting the gist that
this is all to direct
focus to your site right unfiltered
right
so
besides selling fart jars and boobs what
that's your main goal essentially i'm
asking like what is your what are your
goals outside of the shenanigans i'm
trying to be the next big site there's
so much competition out there and i
built this site to be
a competitor to only fans because
i was once a creator on that site and i
did not like their treatment of creators
and
uh and i want to be you know a founder
of a site and i'm a creator that wants
to
represent other creators and have their
best interest at heart um and
i think yeah i wanna i wanna
build traffic to my site i want to bring
attention to that and i also want to
teach other women how they can do this
type of work that i do
and how they can also be entrepreneurs
adult entertainment has that always been
an interest of yours
no i actually used to be really really
shy i used to be very closed off
sexually
and just not very in tune and in touch
with my
sexual side at all throughout my 20s i
battled aplastic anemia and autoimmune
illness which
you know in in a lot of ways
destroyed my body and and took away my
health so
doing this type of work and getting in
touch with my sexuality again and with
my femininity it really helped me
fall in love with myself again and feel
confident and feel sexy again and you
know just to know that there's guys out
there that want my boobs wet and my
farts it helps me feel hot again so
you know it's it's fun like it's it's a
cool feeling what do you think is the
biggest misconception people have about
you
i think
that maybe it's just that like i am
just like some like
crazy crazy eccentric weirdo or
something
you know that i'm just like much weirder
than i am i just i'm just like a normal
girl i just spend most of my time at
home with my dogs
chilling watching true crime
documentaries
like i don't go out much i just like to
work
i just like to you know
drip sweat and put them in yeah i just
drip sweat into bottles
you know what the thing is most most of
the time i just like to work i'm a
workaholic who just likes to spend time
with my dogs and my boyfriend and
that's about it i'm actually kind of
boring beneath the boob sweat and the
fart jars and all the craziness i'm
actually i'm pretty boring yeah i think
we we kind of all are when you put it
there yeah you mentioned your boyfriend
is this the same guy the guy from france
that you mentioned yeah
so you guys are still together we're
still together i think it's like going
on almost a year now and it's like super
private we we keep it under wraps and
and i think i'm gonna keep it that way
you know 90 day fiance keeps trying to
get in there with the camera they're
like they're like steph when are you
ready to like come and share more of
this and i'm like
no i don't think so i think so you
no i don't think that i'm ever gonna
come back onto the show with the
relationship i think you know as far as
the 90-day fiance franchise i'll keep it
only strictly like pillow talk or like
little updates here and there
but never will i put my relationship
back in the spotlight like that because
i just saw how destructive it was with
me and my previous partner on the show
and i just would never want to go
through something like that again
it's just not for me you know i i've
reached that point in my life now where
i just rather focus on like my projects
my work my boob sweat and just and
that's it and it's like now i can pick
and choose what i share online and i
don't have to rely on like editors and
producers you know picking and choosing
what they put out there right speaking
of your ex partner have you spoken to
erica at all or not no
and we don't keep in touch um you know
just as far as i know she's doing really
well and she's super happy and i'm just
i'm really happy for her we've both
moved on and we're both doing well
[Music]